bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est au c
es avec marine de la société able to you
alors c'est une techno qui est
complètement incroyable qui risque de
révolutionner votre vie demain rien que
ça est ce que tu peux nous la présenter
c'est vraiment un truc de dingue
[Musique]
je mets la pression j'arrive comme ça
vibre à laissac c'est incroyable à
l'heure actuelle a développé une
technologie qui permet de sang
son écran
peu collant des cantons sont pas fiables
la surface il dit
sans rien
ça donne ma nage c'est un écran
[Musique]
sympa d'avoir une information
tactique on va pas
l'écran est plus utile
le grand patron de générer des micro
vibrations sur un écran ce qui permet de
sentir c'est
comme on n'a pas tout
gernez
touché parce que explique à sa mort dipc
ça va être compliqué malheureusement
aujourd'hui on n'a pas cette techno mais
c'est vrai que alors je l'essayé le coup
moi je suis
on parlait très simplement parce que on
va imaginer un grand âge en crédit-bail
allait cependant smartphones imaginons
par exemple j'ai ici plusieurs traits
plusieurs niveaux à chaque fois que je
passe sur un ca me fait comme si j'avais
quelque chose sur le doigt qui bougeait
comme si vous passez votre doigt sur une
surface où il y aurait une petite un
petit volume voilà un petit cran pour le
sens à chaque fois et c'est hyper dingue
parce que on imagine que cette cette
techno en réalité on puisse lorsque dans
nos smartphone par exemple vous
déverrouillez nous sentons vibrations
pas vous sentez le d'écran le crantage
mais si c'est ça par exemple clic
épingle avec le 3d tâches qu'on va
trouver
on pouvait sentir quelque chose de
différent sur notre doit sentir déclic
quand on nous quand enfin quand on
navigue donc ça c'est vrai que c'est
génial
du coup on peut l'imaginer sur les
smartphones tu me parlais de
l'automobile aussi tous les écrans
tactiles
alors
robin aujourd'hui les vols dans les
voitures on a besoin
qui dit plus
parce que voilà les constructeurs
d'avoir distrait un peu partout de
femmes c'est que c'est à cause des
problèmes de sécurité parce que leur
rôle est par exemple la quantification
ça va du monde
d'avoir omis ce qu'on doit y 2
en tout cas
les constructeurs de mobiles pape a cité
la terrible
et ces contrôles dans les comptes
activés
ça a vraiment un
dans la voiture et senti manque
d'information
c'est génial alors du coup on peut
l'imaginer dans l'automobile dans les
smartphones qu'est-ce que vous avez
imaginé comme application encore alors
qu'on travaille aussi avec des nations
voyons d'abord parce qu'en fait ça
personnes non voyantes
en train de dire des études en bête pour
votre venue des applications mobiles
[Musique]
et voilà n'y a pas d'application
différents tempête
on peut imaginer 7
logique en dés
et fenêtres
complètement en train de révolutionner
toute la navigation au niveau des écrans
poêle avec l'amour
elle est en hausse aussi thater
alors sans devoir dévoiler deux soldes
sont probablement confidentiel avec qui
où est ce qu'on va pouvoir nous
retrouver demain
alors là c'est un peu le bordel parce
que j'ai forcément mais il ya des
chances qu'ils ont été ou sont
officielles ou pas alors y'a des choses
je ne marche plus value des volets en
fait mais pas encore vous dire
vous la retrouverez dans
fatima
quand les voitures et dans les
smartphones hissé
voilà en fait il faut juste
travailler avec tous les
en fait
premier état apple samsung est en 3e tu
dois avoir du wawel tu dois
ouais voilà tous les gros contact avec
nous
et l'après mon amour au challenge en
fait c'est
la techno dans la fabrication d'é
cette semaine par la voir sur des
du coup on a ici c'est facile mais après
nous avoir offert un dossier
- et qu'on travaille avec des labos de
recherche
vraiment voilà me utilisé
comme ça on retrouve sur tout type
d'écran
d'un point de vue purement techno
comment ça se passe comment ça compte y
aller
alors tu apprends techno enfin tout
devient utilise un écran normal
quelques caves ajouté
sur laquelle on dit
les actionnaires petite zone
des compétiteurs sont notamment cités
une vibration place
le fond la qualité
c'est d'être ma passion je suis un peu
largué la crise ça me parle pas du tout
non non je suis confiante smb qui brasse
envoyé sur les cours
la coordination a modifié le battement
du doigt
on va passer la surface
et en fait on joue avec le signal bas du
classement
envoyez on va pouvoir
bien que
d'abord dû
joue avec ça et en fait c'est en défens
libration on a tous bords
en droit c'est
on n'a plus son électrique
vraiment une châtaigne qua non non ça
c'est vraiment vraiment
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est
bluffant sont acceptables si vous
hésitez plus qu'en même temps
depuis deux ans voilà way
la technologie u
et vous votre idée l'idée de
de crise d'exposer cette techno pouvoir
le proposer cette manière là ça vient
d'où cette fois il c'est un constat la
base si on n'a pas de cible
ce temps par 27
internationale
m
c'est incroyable de l'appliquer
des écrans tactiles
à la base c'était pas du tout adapté
pour
rechercher dit ça mais
pas apporté la sto
sur sur un smartphone
on travaille pour ça génial et vous êtes
d'avion nice grenoble
bravo sont
ne voit on a qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter du goût
un bac
maintenant
c'était bien c'était
voyager
dames et en espagnol
vous pouvez plus là bon ben écoute merci
beaucoup seule bonne continuation je
vous invite vous à me dire ce que vous
en pensez parce que c'est vrai qu'on va
très bien typiquement avec ce genre de
start-ups et des startups comme ça qui
demain vont changer notre quotidien vont
changer notre expérience utilisateur sur
tous types de produits
là on est sur des écrans mais il ya
aussi énormément d'applications vous me
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce que ça pourrait vous
intéresser ce que vous percevez un petit
peu les les applications seront pouvoir
en faire mettez moi tout ça comme d'hab
vous invite à me laisser des jolies
pousse à vous abonner
on reste connectés merci beaucoup à
bientôt au tchad